in early 2020 the uk endured one of the
worst waves of covid anywhere in the
world key failings around testing a
flawed pandemic plan and lockdown all
contributed
this is what we now recognize as the
uk's pandemic you can see two
catastrophic waves of infection and we
only have this picture because of
testing
zoom into march 2020 and cases look like
they were very low because back then we
were only testing in hospitals cases
were in fact in the tens of thousands it
left a colossal blind spot and goes some
way to explain why even our most senior
politicians could shrug off emerging
health advice i'm shaking hands
continues i was at a hospital the other
night where i think there were a few
there were actually a few coronavirus
patients and i shook hands with
everybody you'll be pleased to know but
one thing we could measure even at the
very beginning was deaths from covid
look at march again on the ninth with
five recorded deaths science advisors
were undecided on lockdown why well the
thinking was it would have to last for a
year or more and people wouldn't comply
it's not just a matter of what you do it
is also a matter of when you do it
because anything we do we've got to be
able to sustain but by march 13th deaths
had tripled modelling studies were
starting to show mortality could reach
hundreds of thousands but still no
lockdown could the idea of herd immunity
have played a role the idea described by
mps is fatalistic that the wave of
infection would only end when the
majority were infected we think that
this virus is likely to be one that
comes back year on year
become like a seasonal virus and
communities will become immune to it and
that's going to be an important part of
controlling this longer term
sixty percent
sixty percent is the sort of figure you
need to get hurt
immunity in the next five days deaths
more than quadrupled the modelling data
was nothing short of terrifying but
still no lockdown so what happened well
a wake-up call from italy
sky news witnessed intensive care units
in the city of bergamo overwhelmed by
covid italy's outbreak only a week or
two ahead of hours
seeing was finally believing and the uk
went to lockdown four days later a
decisive step but one that came weeks
too late for tens of thousands of people
that died in the uk's first wave